I think we should call them demons he
had a disease he had alcoholism and it's
an illness and I think we've got to get
over this idea that it's some sort of
you know I don't like that the language
that sometimes are used about alcoholism
it's an illness is a disease some people
get it some people don't the same as
cancer or diabetes or ask for anything
else and it's true that every time
Charles or you or me or anybody else
every time we lift a glass that's the
choice that we make but we don't make a
choice to become alcoholic that is an
illness that hit some people and doesn't
hit others and you're right the Charles
is a wonderful wonderful man and what
what's been you know really moving about
this week is that yes of course this is
inevitably focused on his drinking and
quite right too because that was part of
him and clearly as you say it's been as
part of the cause of death but the
reality is lots and lots of people have
been remembering everything about
Charles I mean I've just been an event
here at glasgow university where he was
once the rector and I mean you know you
don't normally hear people saying that
they love a politician but the people
did love Chuck people here at the
University love Charles Kennedy and I
think that it's just tragic that he's
gone of course it is but I think that
this point about alcoholism is that
actually it's probably the thing that
gave him if you like that vulnerability
that made people realize he was a very
very very human politician but those
that didn't get an opportunity to to
read your blog earlier on in the week
you you were talking then about you know
your experience of your friendship with
him and how you managed to or how he
talked about when he was drinking or
when he wasn't drinking and the code
that you have perhaps you could just for
people that didn't have an opportunity
to read that blog give us an insight
into what you were saying what it was
who know the fact is that I think I
probably because I did too had my own
difficulties alcohol I probably was one
of the few people in the Westminster
village if you like the Charles did talk
to about his drinking we talked about it
a lot and I you know it was partly in
jest because of the whole phone hacking
thing but we used to have this little
code which was health fine health good
health okay
health not so good and health not so
good meant that he was feeling you know
I that he was about to drink or he was
drinking and the thing is that Charles
did go for quite long periods of that
drinking but I don't think he ever
really reached that point that I was
fortunate up to reach actually not far
from here in the hospital you have to
reach the point yourself where you say
do you know what these people have been
telling me I've got to stop they're
actually right but they can't do it only
I can and I don't think Charles ever
quite got to that and that is in the end
the tragedy and of course it's somebody
said in one of the interviews I just did
a few moments ago here do was politics
and Westminster blame when the answer is
no yes it's an easy place to drink but I
think the whole of Britain is an easy
place to drink we've got a very very
dangerous drinking culture in Britain
and a lot of people fall victim to that
how did he cope with you know when he
was drinking he must have as far as
Donald was concerned his young lad he
must have found that quite a challenge
as well and quite difficult to to
realize that he had he had this young
boy and he had all those
responsibilities but he still you know
he had this disease that he couldn't
conquer I mean I saw Charles with Donald
a fair bit especially up here we used to
have used to we go on holiday up in this
constituency would see them a lot and
Charles and Donaldson them to get
together was fantastic you know that
they were he was a really really loving
dad and Donald is a fantastic boy and I
thought that the you know the family
today recognizing that those tributes in
the commons that Donal was able to see
you probably won't remember and he
probably could have taken in at a time
but he'll have that on tape burhan sod
it'll be there forever of all these
people who will become figures in
history prime ministers and the like
saying things about his dad that will be
there forever so of course like any
family member you won't you do of course
you worry about other people but this is
the thing you have to understand about
about alcohol is that
if P I sometimes think that those who
don't understand alcoholism they sort of
look at it and I understand this guy's
numbers do it myself you see people
somebody's who's who's so clearly
gripped by this and has got a wife or a
husband or children or parents or
whatever and you want to say look you
know do you realize what you're doing to
yourself and to other people and of
course they do realize it but they but
you can't stop it and I've been in that
position where you you're inundated with
people saying you destroy your life
you're you're ruining your future you're
making everybody unhappy and I've been
there and and the more people say that
you to be absolutely Frank often the
worse it gets and for me I was
incredibly lucky because I was I hit
rock bottom and I realized it was rock
bottom and I realized unless I faced up
to that and I had a fantastic support
medical support particularly and family
support particularly my partner Fiona I
had all that and I was able to get
through it but a lot of people can't get
through that Charles actually has lived
with this disease for a long long time
he's he's been he's done some amazing
things even while he's had it but I you
know I those tributes the other day they
were very moving they're very powerful
and as the cliche goes it's the house of
commons at its best but i think there's
something else that MPs have to do they
have to face up to the fact that they
have to take the lead in challenging and
changing the culture of alcohol that
we've got in our country which i'm
telling is i think is worse than
anywhere in the world and unless we face
up to that there are going to be so many
more people that nobody will be talking
about on the television that nobody will
be holding memorial services for it
buildings like this they'll just be
another victim of alcohol and you know
here in Scotland I'm Jennifer not an SMP
person by any means but the SNP
government to be fair to them they've
done a lot of good stuff on alcohol
abuse some considerable political
showing some political courage and doing
it and the Westminster Government were
afraid did not make
have gone from minimum unit pricing it
would have made a difference they could
have gone for putting in proper
education about what alcohol does and
the damage it's doing to people but they
didn't do that and I think the whole
thing I mean it's probably not the day
to get on a soapbox but you know just
which is going to take stock of the
culture that we're in I remember talk to
Charles about this in this country when
you try not to drink you always have to
explain what you're not drinking you
never ever have to explain why you're
drinking would you have a drink yes take
it we have a drink Gavin a glass of
water oh you're not drinking are you
driving you're pregnant whatever it
might be and that's a cultural shift and
you know I look at sport i watch
sporting the television all the time
drowning in camp is drowning and
gambling and alcohol and if we don't
face up to it then there are going to be
a lot more people like Charles and we've
just got to I think face up to that and
do something and the politicians you
paid the tributes in the commons they
have got to take the lead and for those
that are watching this afternoon
Alistair and they can see how you have
turned your life around with the help of
Fiona and you say the medical team as
well as opposed to what happened to
Charlie Kennedy is it is it as simple is
it as simple as making a choice even
though it is the disease what what
advice would you offer to people who are
who are struggling with a bottle at the
moment
it's very difficult to give advice to
people because you know we're all
individuals will all have our own
struggles and all have to deal with them
but I've met a lot of people in my time
we've had alcohol problems and someone
got through it and and some happen but I
do think that it's it's about coming to
this point of understanding a genuine
point of understanding in yourself that
it's got to stop and and that sounds
very very simple but getting to that
point is really really difficult and to
be honest is not held by people just
saying to you pull yourself together
just don't do it because that doesn't
work they have to be to be led to that
point by themselves with the help of
other people a chance and lots of people
who tried to do that and for some
various points those people family and
friends and doctors they were successful
but the most important thing you've got
to do I think this is the same for the
country I think both as individuals and
the country we have the only way to deal
with the problems to face up to the
scale of the problem following up on the
train up today I was sitting there and
about two seats away I was and you get
an eye for these things and I can spot
people with drink problems and there's a
couple of people talking and this guy he
was he was saying to his wife or his
partner I don't know what the
relationship was and she was giving you
a bit of a hard time about his drinking
and he was saying we talking about it
didn't have a drink all day yesterday
until nine o'clock and that's a classic
sort of you know we persuade ourselves
that we're not really drinking at all I
did that for years i'm not you know i
know how it works and ultimately i think
we've got to get your position where as
a culture as a country we don't live in
a place where students have to feel they
get drunk in their first week otherwise
there's something weird about them where
people can go to football matches
without thinking well you can only get
you're going to watch football in a pub
you know you can't you either go to the
ground or you watching their pub and
your drink well if you lose you drown
your sorrows where if you drink your
celebrate we're drowning culturally in a
sea of alcohol thank you for joining us
on